[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit heinz
wolf und marietta slomka guten abend vor
schönstem alpen panorama wird olaf
scholz morgen dem g7-gipfel eröffnen
wobei er selbst die erwartungs latte
nicht zu hoch gehängt sehen will man
werde in ellmau keine berge versetzen
sagte er heute dieses naheliegenden
wortspiel wird in den nächsten tagen
vermutlich noch häufiger zu hören sein
wenn vom fuße der zugspitze berichtet
wird ursprünglich waren die g7 gipfel
aber tatsächlich keine veranstaltungen
bei denen verbindliche entscheidungen
getroffen wurden begonnen hatte das
ganze jahr schon in den 70er jahren als
kamingespräch zum formlosen austausch
mal in ruhe über die weltlage reden ohne
spiegel striche auf papier setzen zu
müssen
das hat sich im laufe der zeit etwas
geändert und den elmau wird mindestens
eine demonstration der geschlossenheit
erwartet dann ja pontzen berichtet
eines ist wie immer das große schauspiel
auf der landebahn vor gut einer halben
stunde sitzt die air force one auf mit
dem us präsidenten
zuvor ist bereits der französische
eingetroffen die bayern machen ihr
brauchtum und sich selbst gern zur
kulisse
als erster kommt am nachmittag der
gastgeber an olaf scholz bevor es per
heli weitergeht richtung elbe
berge versetzen werde man nicht bei
diesem gipfel in den bergen so der
kanzler ungewohnt poetisch vorab per
video und dann ganz nüchtern dieser
gesprächs klopp hat mal angefangen als
g6 mit sechs staaten als helmut schmidt
alle zusammen gerufen hat um darüber zu
reden wie wir mit der damaligen ölkrise
umgehen jetzt ist es wichtig dass wir
die heutige situation besprechen und
gleichzeitig dafür sorge tragen dass wir
den menschengemachten klimawandel
aufhalten der war mal als top thema
vorgesehen inzwischen aber überlagert
die ukraine alles die sich zuspitzende
welthunger krise zählt zu den
drängendsten themen der klimawandel
bleibt auf der agenda auch mit den
gastländern unter anderem indien und
indonesien die aber will man auch
stärker für den krieg sensibilisieren
zu viele länder sagen das ist ein
europäischer krieg der wirtschaftliche
probleme verursacht die wir wirklich
nicht gebrauchen können dadurch wächst
der druck auf die menschen in der
ukraine auch einen schlechten frieden zu
akzeptieren
pünktlich zum gipfel staat sollte putin
dass moskau eine nachricht die in ellmau
als er vergiftete gruß ankam und genauso
wohl auch gemeint war belarus werde er
mit atomwaffenfähigen raketen ausstatten
zudem intensivierte russland noch einmal
seine angriffe in der ukraine
die situation war wohl nie düstere vor
einem gipfel was sich mancher orts auch
bei den protesten spiegelte in münchen
waren statt der erwarteten 20 nur 5000
zugegen ganz viele menschen sind
verunsichert ob man jetzt gerade für
klimagerechtigkeit für soziale
gerechtigkeit gegen die die sich immer
draußen auf die straße gehen soll oder
ob man sie nicht sogar unterstützen muss
bei der frage der konfrontation in der
ukraine
heute abend gibt es weitere aktionen ein
rotes peace zeichen von greenpeace und
an der skisprungschanze in garmisch an
die gipfelteilnehmer eine frage schafft
ihr den absprung
wir wollen damit sagen dass wir wirklich
auf die staats und regierungschefs
zählen konkrete maßnahmen zu beschließen
nicht nur warme worte zu finden um uns
alle um die welt aus diesen krisen
herauszuführen also den absprung aus den
krisen zu schaffen für skispringer gilt
am ende hängt es von vielen faktoren ab
wie weit man kommt egal wie lang der
anlauf ist ziemlich ähnliches gilt wohl
für die g7 teilnehmer in ellmau der wind
kommt diesmal sozusagen von vorn
und unserer us korrespondent nrt wissen
ist auch in ellmosen garmisch immer mit
welchen erwartungen welche agenda ist
der amerikanische präsident nach ellmau
gereist
also so weit will eigentlich das
schaffen was ein politikwissenschaftler
gerade in washington war sehr gut
beschrieben hat die einigkeit die ja nur
eine reaktion war auf einen schock
nämlich den ukraine krieg die villa und
muss er eigentlich so sagen die experten
umwandeln in einen längeren zusammenhalt
einen langfristigen zusammenhalt auf der
basis von gemeinsamen zielen und einem
gemeinsamen plan und das will man tun
allen voran natürlich mit dem thema
ukraine das heißt weiter ausbau der
militärischen unterstützt unterstützung
da wollen alle etwas zu beitragen
zweiter ein wiederaufbauplan einen
marshall-plan sowie in die
bundesregierung vorgeschlagen hat aber
joe biden möchte gerne auch verhindern
dass wladimir putin sich weiterhin ich
sag's mal salopp eine goldene nase
verdient denn die ölpreise sind trotz
der sanktionen oder auch wegen der
sanktionen in den letzten monaten so in
die höhe geschossen dass er promo 120
milliarden dollar einnimmt das ist 50
prozent mehr als vor ausbruch dieses
ukraine kriegs der will der us präsident
eine preisobergrenze und es scheint so
zu sein als würden die anderen damit
ziehen das heißt man kann dann öl weiter
beziehen aber nicht mehr als eine
obergrenze bezahlen man hofft darauf
dass eben auch die gastländer mitmachen
wie indien indonesien und südafrika und
wenn man da einigkeit findet dann
vielleicht auch mehr einigkeit dabei wie
man gemeinsam den kampf gegen den
klimawandel angehen kann sich
gegenseitig helfen kann die
industrienationen den entwicklungs und
schwellenländern helfen können die
bundesregierung sagt so hören wir hier
dass man auf einem guten weg ist es gibt
ein gutes gefühl von geschlossenheit
aber am ende werden wir dann in der
abschlusserklärung eben sehen ob sie mit
wirklichen taten dann auch die latten
überspringen die sie ja gerade selbst
gelegt haben danke schneller für diese
vorausschauen bei seiner abreise aus den
usa hat joe biden jedenfalls an land in
aufruhr hinterlassen die entscheidung
des obersten gerichtshofs das ist dahin
geltende landesweite abtreibungsrecht zu
kippen ist auch für ihn an desaster
etliche republikanisch regierten
bundesstaaten haben umgehend
abtreibungsverbote in kraft gesetzt die
teils so radikal sind dass sie sogar
schwangerschafts abbrüche aus
medizinischen gründen versagen für
amerikas klerikale fundamentalisten ist
dass sein ideologischer sieg einen
etappensieg denn es geht ihnen nicht nur
um das abtreibungs thema anderfalls
berichtet aus den usa
legalisiert die abtreibung wieder
[Applaus]
leider braucht es manchmal fiel um
menschen aufzuwecken
ich wünschte es wäre nicht so weit
gekommen
der weckruf das kippen einer fast 50
jahre alten entscheidung
1973 wurde in den usa das recht auf
abtreibung in der verfassung verankert
gestern hat er seit trump mehrheitlich
konservativ besetzte oberste gerichtshof
dass zurückgezogen in fast der hälfte
der 50 bundesstaaten treten ab jetzt
abtreibungsverbote oder harte
restriktionen in kraft
ihre vergangenheit könnte jetzt die
zukunft werden von millionen frauen in
den usa sollen joe jonas ist 1966
schwanger mit 19 die eltern streng
katholisch sie will das kind nicht
austragen über kontakte bekommt sie eine
nummer ein mann kam mit einem auto und
holte mich ab wir fuhren eine wirklich
lange strecke zu einem bauernhaus ein
mann mit einer maske kamen hier rein ich
hoffe er war arzt aber ich weiß es nicht
er hat nicht mit mir gesprochen
die abtreibung wurde ohne betäubung
durchgeführt
die 67 jährige ist mittlerweile
großmutter seit damals engagiert sie
sich in der seit jahren schwelenden
debatte um abtreibungsrecht es war ihre
tochter die ihr gestern mitteilte was
passiert ist
das war ein schlag ins gesicht
und jetzt
wir werden sicherstellen dass alle
frauen die eine abtreibung brauchen
einen weg finden werden diese zu
bekommen
aber ferro sondern wie für viele andere
hier am tag danach die einzige
konsequenz wir müssen wählen wir müssen
politiker wählen die gegen das urteil
sind
und nicht aufgeben heißt es trotzdem
mein land und ich werde es mir
zurückholen
ob das tatsächlich ein weckruf war das
werden die kommenden monate zeigen
weitere nachrichten jetzt von 1 in
norwegen vermuten die behörden nach den
tödlichen schüssen in einem ausgeführt
lyn oslo einen islamistischen terror akt
zwei menschen wurden bei dem angriff
getötet und mehr als 20 verletzt die
polizei konnte den mutmaßlichen täter
festnehmen eine norweger mit iranischen
wurzeln
die schüsse waren unter anderem vor
einer bei homosexuellen beliebten bar
gefallen eine für heute geplante pride
parade wurde abgesagt dennoch ging viele
auf die straße um für die rechte ihrer
menschen zu demonstrieren
in georgien haben zehntausende für einen
eu beitritt ihres landes demonstriert
bei der kundgebung in tiflis gestern am
späten abend warfen sie der regierung
vor sich nicht ausreichend dafür
eingesetzt zu haben dass die eu georgien
zum beitrittskandidaten erklärt der
ukrainische präsident lenski versicherte
den demonstranten in einer
videobotschaft sein land werde georgien
helfen den weg nach europa zu gehen
in berlin ermittelt der staatsschutz der
kriminalpolizei wegen des gefälschten
video anrufs eines vermeintlichen vitali
klitschko ein unbekannter hatte bei
europäischen bürgermeistern auch in
berlin bei franziska giffey angerufen
der auf dem bildschirm genauso aussah
und sprach wie der käfer bürgermeister
dann aber wegen seltsamer fragen auffiel
es war offenbar eine sorgfältig
manipulierte video schalte ein
sogenanntes die fake wer dahinter steckt
ist unklar
in nordrhein westfalen haben cdu und
grüne den nächsten schritt zu einer
gemeinsamen regierung gemacht beide
landesparteitages stimmten dem
ausgehandelten koalitionsvertrag zu
damit steht der wiederwahl von
ministerpräsident wüst am dienstag im
landtag praktisch nichts mehr im weg bei
der cdu gab es bei rund 600 delegierten
nur vier gegenstimmen zum
koalitionsvertrag bei den grünen gab es
eine 85 mehrheit deren landeschefin
neubauer soll superministerin für
wirtschaft klima und energie werden
zu den verschiedenen denkwürdigen
momenten im laufe des insgesamt
dreitägigen bundesparteitag der linken
gehörte gestern der auftritt des
thüringer ministerpräsidenten ramelow
der ist offenkundig für notwendig hielt
seine partei freunde und freundinnen
darüber aufzuklären dass wladimir putin
kein linker ist
russlands angriffskrieg ist für die
linke jedenfalls ein problem mehr bei
ihrer suche nach gemeinsamen positionen
in politischen grundsatzfragen
diese suche geht ja schon sehr lange und
führte die partei bei der bundestagswahl
nicht mal mehr über die
fünf-prozent-hürde
und so war auch dieser parteitag wieder
ein krisentreffen andrea maurer
berichtet sie sollen die linke jetzt aus
der krise führen martin schulden und
janine wissler vor allem wissler gewählt
mit schwachen ergebnis 57,5 prozent für
die alte jetzt neue parteichefin vor
einem jahr waren es noch 84 prozent
dazwischen liegen wahlniederlagen
sexismus vorwürfe der rücktritt ihrer
crew parteichefin
letzten wochen monate waren ja auch gab
es ja auch den einen oder anderen
ja auch auseinandersetzungen jetzt auch
in den letzten tagen vor dem parteitag
auch noch mal also von daher war das
jetzt in der schwierigen situation ich
sag mal so ich habe eine deutliche
mehrheit der neue an wissler seite
martin schade waren bislang coo
fraktionschef im europäischen parlament
glaube das signal ist eindeutig wir
haben verstanden als linke wir sind
wieder da als linke und das ist auch das
signal dass dieser parteitag nach außen
sendet an die bürgerinnen und bürger
noch während wissler und schirdewahn
glückwünsche entgegennehmen wird die
aufbruchstimmung getrübt betroffene von
linkem itu und sexismus sind empört über
vissers wiederwahl
dass wir personen die spitze und
angeblich familie zwischen partei setzen
die ganz klar täterschutz betreiben
minute freunde welche veränderung reden
aber sie heute nicht gesagt komm vereine
präsent auf dem parteitag auch der
machtkampf mit dem parteiflügel um sahra
wagenknecht weder wissler noch schöne
waren waren dort favorit am mittag
stimmt sich wissler persönlich gegen
einen änderungsantrag von wagenknecht
und anderen der die mitschuld des
westens am ukraine krieg festhalten will
änderungsantrag abgeräumt der unmut
derjenigen aber die mehr rückbesinnung
weniger programmatische erneuerung
wollen wohl noch lange nicht die frage
wieso wieder ausreichend tatsächlich
einen neuanfang
repräsentieren können und auch dann in
der weiteren folge ist schon einen
wirklichen neuanfang in der partei
kommen kann dieses offen ob die
unzufriedenen der neuen parteiführung
nun folgen die linke den aufbruch
schafft das alles ist mit dem heutigen
tag noch nicht entschieden
und jetzt die lottozahlen dieses
samstags sie lauten wie immer ohne
gewähr
24 21 28 33 43 superzahl 5 weitere
gewinnzahlen finden sie auf lotto zdf de
und im zdf text auf seite 55 6 die
wetteraussichten morgen scheint im osten
und südosten die sonne und es bleibt
trocken sonst sind zahlreiche wolken
unterwegs und es entwickeln sich schauer
und teils kräftige gewitter die
temperatur steigt auf werte von 22 bis
33 grad auch in den nächsten tagen muss
mit schauern und heftigen gewittern
gerechnet werden am montag wird es im
osten bis 35 grad heiß sonst liegen die
höchstwerte bei 22 bis 29 grad
das war es von uns jetzt geht es weiter
mit dem sportstudio und gegen 0.30 gibt
es dann die nächste heute express und
morgen auf wiedersehen wieder sinn
[Musik]